il sans détour corinne lepage vrai pour
à nos questions bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes président du
mouvement écologiste cap21 avocate vous
représentiez les collectivités locales à
ce procès de la catastrophe de l'erika
vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'environnement pourquoi la justice
reconnaît aujourd'hui le préjudice
écologique dans cette catastrophe alors
que ça n'avait jamais été fait avant on
a un autre exemple en tête qui est celui
que vous connaissez bien la moc à nice
alors sur la moco k10 le principe avait
été admis mais on avait constaté qu'il y
avait plus de dommages 14 ans plus tard
et eu deux petites décide de décision en
france qui avait déjà été rendu mais
c'est la première fois qu'ils à une
reconnaissance avec l'application d'un
principe aussi vaste et par exemple
indemnisation pour la lpo la ligue de
protection des oiseaux des oiseaux morts
pour les collectivités locales il ya le
principe de la réparation du préjudice
écologique et le morbihan par exemple
récupère quelques milliers d'euros à ce
titre
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ça va
changer que dans l'équation économique d
affréteurs et de toute la chaîne du
transport pétrolier on va savoir qu'une
catastrophe en europe et notamment en
france ça peut coûter très cher et qu'il
vaut mieux prendre des bateaux qui sont
ces cures plutôt que d'en prendre des
poubelles
un mot sur la condamnation de total je
dirais que pour les collectivités
locales c'est une satisfaction d'abord
psychologique parce qu'elle a vu le
sentiment d'être méprisés au départ de
ce dossier et puis juridique dans la
mesure il est essentiel que tous les
acteurs de la chaîne puis cette
responsable ici vous savez ce qu'a dit
le tribunal c'est du bon sens et
d'écouté totale vous avez contrôler ce
bateau vous avez donné un feu vert vous
avez accepté de le prendre vous saviez
qu'il était mauvais état vous avez
commis une imprudence et voilà 192
millions d'euros c'est le maximum qu'ils
pouvaient être obtenues non c'est pas le
maximum puisque a pas de plafond pour la
réparation des dommages humains pour les
sanctions pénales mais pas pour la
réparation des dommages c'est une somme
importante
c'est moins que ce qu'on espérait les et
combien l'évaluation du préjudice
écologique les communes n'en ont pas eu
par contre le tribunal a été assez
généreux en ce qui concerne l'atteinte à
l'image de marque puisque par exemple
les communes que je défends ont reçu
entre un million et demi et cinq cent
mille euros
les pétroliers disent que les parties
civiles réclamaient un milliard d'euros
en simple break ça d'abord en plus met
donc un peu plus que 180
est ce que est ce que est ce que c'est
un quand même un demi échec ou est-ce
que vous considérez que les communes ont
été indemnisées quand même à la hauteur
du préjudice subit pas de notre à la
totalité du préjudice subi certainement
pas parce qu'il ya toute une partie du
prêt phyllis toute façon qu'on n'arrive
jamais évaluer convenablement
mais ce n'est certainement pas un échec
en cas d'échec en échec non c'est une
victoire pour les collectivités locales
et les parties civiles
au moment où l'on parle j'allais dire
des dizaines mais peut-être moins
peut-être plus je ne sais pas de bateaux
poubelles sillonnent les
mers du globe que faire contre cela ce
qu'on pensait sincèrement que ce
jugement d'aujourd'hui va être dissuasif
côté il va être certainement dissuasif
ou moins pour les côtes européennes qui
s'est passé en france à mon avis est
intéressant au niveau de l'europe et du
reste je plaide devant la cour de
justice mardi prochain sur la suite du
procès erika en ce qui concerne la
notion de déchets et donc cela intéresse
toute l'europe
vous savez les états unis ont changé
leur législation et grâce à ça mais il
ya plus de bateaux poubelles aux états
unis bien ce qui vient de se passer avec
les ricains en france j'espère que ce
sera la même conséquence mais ses phares
de l'ego de mesures nationales
non c'est un changement de jurisprudence
mais peut-être annonciateur d'un
changement de législation sur la
responsabilité de tous les acteurs car
aujourd'hui les affréteurs continue à
n'être pas responsable
il n'est pas admissible dans la société
contemporaine que un acteur économique
puisse dire - quoique je fasse je me
suis jamais responsable c'est à pau il
faut rappeler que total n'a dans la
sphère de l'erika n'a pas été condamné
en il a été condamné parce qu'il avait
fait le contrôle du bateau merci
beaucoup quand il n'empêche d'ailleurs
répondu à nos questions